And the answer here is as follows--so first of all, it's important to notice that
a RAM that has the if-better function available is at least as powerful as a normal RAM
because all we're adding is this additional instruction
but we can still do anything that we could do before.
So this here is clearly a check mark.
Vertex cover, independent set, and clique would be solvable in exponential time.
Also, if we have this if-better function available.
And the second thing is that in the well sort of programming example that we just had
we also saw that the if-better function is so powerful that it will allow us to solve
vertex cover, independent set, and clique in polynomial time
if we have the if-better function available.
And of course this one down here, that unfortunately has to stay blank
but not because we're sure that these problems, vertex cover, independent set, and clique
don't have a polynomial time algorithm but simply because we don't really know yet.
We will come back to this matrix picture here in a minute.
But let's turn our attention back to the RAM machine for a moment now.